this week's 48 hours investigates a new
suspect in the disappearance of a child
that made international headlines
madeleine mccann was just
three years old in 2007 when she
vanished from her bed at a resort in
portugal while vacationing with her
family
48 hours correspondent peter van sant
looks at the german suspect christian
bruckner
and why authorities believe he may know
what happened
in may of 2007 british doctors jerry
and kate mccann were on vacation with
their children
at a beach resort in prior deluge
portugal
as they had done every night the mccanns
left their children
asleep in their apartment and went to
meet friends for
dinner about 50 yards away jane hill is
a bbc
news anchor who covered madeleine's
story and
the friends would take turns and just
check on their sleeping children
at 10 pm when it was kate's turn she
found
this bed madeleine's bed empty
please please do not hear sir please
don't scare her
please tell us where to find her
despite a global media storm a
multinational search and investigation
years passed with no answers until
this past june a german prisoner has
been identified as a new suspect in the
disappearance of madeleine mccann
german authorities in braunschweig
germany made this announcement
the accused is a sex offender with
several previous convictions
the suspect's name is christian bruckner
he absolutely matches the profile of a
person
who could potentially abduct and or kill
a little girl like madeleine mccann mark
hoffman
is a germany based crime and
intelligence analyst
his cell phone was tracked next to the
crime scene
the night maddie disappeared
jim gamble former head of the uk's child
exploitation
and online protection center is hopeful
this tragic case
may finally be solved for the first time
in 13 years
i have to say i actually felt here is
a credible suspect
and the big break in this case came in
2017
when bruckner told in a drunken
confession
he told a friend that he knew what had
happened to madeleine mccann
wow peter thank you well powerful story
i hope there's news there
and you can see peter's report the
puzzle solving the madeline mccann case
on 48 hours tomorrow night
at 10 9 central right here on cbs